yoyoyo youtube international master
danny wrench here today for chess calm
and in part one of our chess strategy
series on how to use the little guys i
talked to you about the weaknesses
doubled pawns isolated pawns and
backward pawns and I promised you a
quick review of some practical examples
of how doubled pawns isolated pawns and
backward pawns can be reached in real
chess game so here one very common way
that double pawns are reached is via one
of the most popular openings in the
history of chess which is the Spanish
now the spanish main lines with Bishop
a4 wouldn't necessarily reach double
pawns but often in the Spanish exchange
Bishop takes c6 the real Lopez exchange
variation after black captures back we
here we see double pawns immediately
right now taking the pawn on e5 right
away is not a good idea for white due to
multiple reasons multiple ways for black
to double attack and actually win back
his material but commonly even though
that trade isn't made at some point what
it what does happen is a trade of the D
pawn for the e pawn and in this type of
position we see that another weakness of
having doubled pawns comes to light and
something that we will highlight more as
we talk about the advantages you want to
be able to recognize in terms of the
pollens when you look at a chessboard
which is the ability to have a passed
pawn and a majority which can lead to a
passed pawn here White has a
four-on-three and that's because this
pawn left the D file and went over here
black of course also has a four-on-three
you may be saying but black's pawn
structure is not nearly as mobilers
effective because of the double pawns so
that's a quick example of how doubled
pawns can backfire chess game now here
black has some other compensation for it
being the bishop pair and usually a
quick way to develop the pieces but if
you were to take all the pieces off the
board which is that skill I talked you
about that every chess player needs the
ability to imagine the future of a
position you would see that in terms of
just the pawn structure the long-term
factors White has a serious advantage in
this position and should actually be
winning an endgame like this very easily
essentially playing up an extra pawn
let's take a quick look at a very common
way that an isolated Queen pawn has
reached through many different openings
you can reach an IQ P but one of the
most common is the caro-kann and that
being the pan off Botvinnik very
after c4 Knight f6 Knight c3 at some
point in this line very commonly a trade
is made of the C pawn for the D pawn
either by black taking or by white
taking here the theory is for white to
capture here and either Queen c2 or
Bishop to d2 or both moves and let's say
a few more moves are made we would
actually see a very common example of
what I was talking about in terms of the
isolated pawn potentially offering good
play here we see a position where though
the pawn itself unbias Lee is of course
a weakness white actually has good open
space for the pieces his pawn is
slightly more further advanced in the
pollen e6 and the open files of the C
and E nature will definitely favor white
as well so don't dismiss isolated queen
pawn positions as one that you just
don't want to play they're very dynamic
and lots of fun and leave lots of room
to outplay your opponent if you're a
stronger player whether you're playing
against the weakness or for the weakness
so there's a quick example of an opening
the can reach an isolated Queen pawn
that exact same type of position is
reached commonly through Queen's Indian
move orders like this where after c5
white plays e3 and after take take you
see we've actually made a transposition
which is where you reach the same
position in an early middle game or
opening through a different move or
that's what that word means there let's
see one more example of backward pawns
here before we wrap this thing up and
ship it to Santa Claus one of the most
common and popular ways that a backward
pawn is almost welcomed by one player is
in the open sicilians the special akov
variation where black will often strike
at the center early with the move e5 and
this position black is being extremely
aggressive in terms of the pressure he's
exerting but positionally just in terms
of the pawns we see that a situation
like this has a weak pawn on d6 that
cannot move forward due to capture and
again by definition he's a backward pawn
because his brother pawns have left him
behind
he's backward now it's not the true
definition of a backward pawn and the
one I showed you in the first example
where you can't advance either due to
regular capture or on posad that would
take a white pawn being on let's say the
fifth-ranked holding it back but the
concept that the pawn is stuck and that
his brother pawns have left him behind
he cannot advance due to capture is the
same thing and in this case white has
positional weaknesses to try to take
advantage of usually weaknesses
associated with a backward pawn
is that what's called an outpost square
which is a square that could no longer
be attacked by pawns once again by
definition because the pawns have left a
quick and perhaps slightly more advanced
example for a backward pawn would be
positions like this commonly reached out
of a mirach C bond in an accelerated
dragon or other types of English
openings often the Marco hop is employed
when White has a space advantage which
is putting this knight in to d5 and
after the bishop captures not wanting to
leave that Pony on a dominant Square
right no one likes that it's not a pony
pony white captures back with the e pawn
and this e file is now hitting the
backward pawn now it doesn't seem so
obvious right away that's why I said
this is an advanced example because
there are pieces in the way but at some
point this Pony 7 is a positional
weakness and it is a backward pawn that
cannot advance once due to capture or
twice due to UM passant capture now in
this case this pawn is technically
protecting this square so advancing
allowing capture is a possibility for
black but a weakness has always created
at the end of that capture which is a
weak pawn on d6 on the newly-minted open
file
so this positional idea of popping the
knight in to d5 is a very common one for
white and it's a very clear example of
the potential weaknesses of a backward
pawn hope you guys are enjoying these
videos again remember if you're loving
the live sessions in bullet brawl chess
Thursday's you can follow me on twitter
at daniel wrench and we will see you
around on chess comm hope you enjoyed
this video and I'll see you around on
chess calm